schock bei der weltklimakonferenz in
bonn 2017 sind die co2 emissionen wieder
angestiegen wie gerufen kommen also
projekte die das klimaschädliche
kohlendioxid nachträglich aus der luft
filtern jetzt ist eine kommerzielle
anlage dieser art in betrieb genommen
worden und zwar in ins land und sie
macht aus co2 stein wie diese
technologie tatsächlich funktioniert ob
sie sich lohnt und ob sie sogar die
klimakrise lösen kann jetzt den klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
die idee ist großartig und dabei nicht
einmal besonders kompliziert das
klimaschädliche co2 wird aus der luft
gefiltert und in den untergrund geleitet
das glas reagiert dort mit einem
basaltgestein dass beispielsweise eisen
und kalzium enthält das ergebnis dass
co2 mineralisiert zu karbonat also zu
festem gestein diese versteinerung
funktioniert tatsächlich und jetzt wird
sie zum ersten mal mit der sogenannten
direct er capture technologie kombiniert
das schweizer unternehmen klein works
will beweisen dass sich aircap gelohnt
denn bislang galt diese innovative idee
als wenig effektiv und aufwendig und so
hat die firma eine ihrer anlagen nach
island gebracht wo sie jetzt fleißig co2
schlucken soll und zwar in
zusammenarbeit mit dem isländischen
geothermiekraftwerk handy auch hier wird
das treibhausgas also im wasser gelöst
und in den untergrund gepumpt 400 bis
800 meter tief dort ist der boden von
hydrothermalen quellen durchzogen zwei
jahre dauert es dann etwa bis durch die
chemische reaktion das co2 in karbonat
umgewandelt wird
das wirklich großartiger daran durch
diesen schritt ist das dann
mineralisierte co2 tatsächlich aus dem
verkehr gezogen und für das klima
keineswegs mehr schädlich pro tag sollen
somit mit dieser pilotanlage 135
kilogramm co2 entsorgt werden die
projektleiterin elisabeth er vom
reykjavik energy sagt mit der
integration der kleine words technologie
haben wir nun eine lösung die unabhängig
von emissionsquellen überall dort
einsetzbar ist wo es bei salzgestein
gibt das sind in diesen zeiten
tatsächlich wie ein ziemlich großer
hoffnungsschimmer denn grob gesagt ist
basalt erkaltete lava und somit fast
überall auf der erde zu finden auf dem
meeresgrund besteht zu großen teilen
auf basalt das beteiligte forschungsteam
schätzt dass sich allein in island 400
gigatonnen co2 im basaltgestein lagern
lassen und das ist etwa zehnmal so viel
vom klimagas dass wir menschen derzeit
pro jahr in die atmosphäre schleudern
die verantwortlichen haben also allen
grund optimistisch zu sein so wie der
ceo von rheinbergs christoph gewalt das
potenzial zur skalierung unserer
technologie in kombination mit co2
speicherung ist gewaltig und das nicht
nur hier in island sondern in vielen
anderen regionen mit ähnlichen
gesteinsformationen noch realistisch
gesehen ist längst nicht jeder standort
für diese technologie geeignet der große
nachteil es wird sehr viel flüssigkeit
gebraucht pro tonne co2 etwa 25
kubikmeter
die technologie funktioniert zudem nur
mit einer wärmequelle um das co2
überhaupt erst aus dem filter zu lösen
doch die forschung an solchen
technologien ist dennoch enorm wichtig
für die klimaziele und wir haben hier ja
schon öfter darüber berichtet der
herkömmliche klimaschutz scheinen schon
lange nicht mehr auszureichen um unsere
erde vor einem klimakollaps kollaps zu
bewahren
das bestätigen auch die neuesten zahlen
passen zur weltklimakonferenz in bonn
kommt ein forschungsteam das global
carbon project zu einem fairen ergebnis
nach drei jahren stagnation werden die
globalen co2 emissionen im jahr 2017
wieder ansteigen warum also nicht auf
solche techniken des geo-engineering
zurückgreifen vor allem wenn die basis
dafür stimmt denn ja potenzial ist da
denn wie gesagt wenn der klimakiller
kohlendioxid dauerhaft in großen mengen
aus der luft entfernt werden würde
könnte man den co2 gehalt der atmosphäre
tatsächlich wieder auf den
ursprünglichen wert reduzieren
unter diesen umständen sollte man auch
darüber hinwegsehen dass die
finanzierung im moment noch kaum zu
stemmen ist davon fahren ist unfassbar
teuer pro tonne kostet die co2
abscheidung derzeit mehrere hundert euro
das zeigen erfahrungswerte der schweizer
anlagen das unternehmen selbst rechnet
damit dass der preis demnächst auf etwa
100 euro sinkt dort selbst das ist
vergleichsweise teuer der plan der firma
ist es das gespeicherte kohlendioxid zu
verkaufen und zwar an regierungen
organisationen und einzelpersonen die
sich damit klimaneutralität erkaufen
können wenn ihr kein video zu diesem
thema und auch zu allen themen verpassen
wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein
video hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken 2016 stellt neuen klima
negativ rekord auf ja auf 2016 war kein
gutes jahr für den klimawandel ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran